i'll just read casey's words so they
stand on their own and casey seems to be
like a really nice guy actually very
affable i've met him in person he's
quite nice so i don't think he intended
this to be super critical yet it was and
he said ah the founder of a
seven-year-old gmail skin who took a
year off of product development to start
a venture fund has raised 75 million
from the chain smokers to build an early
version in quotes of an outlook
compatible
service that will be available and in
quotes next year and so this is riddled
with errors and so of course that was
quite embarrassing for a journalist to
have this many errors in one tweet it
also
is dunking it's just straight up dunking
very careful when you dunk because if
you're wrong and you get blocked or you
hit the rim and you fall on your face
it's quite embarrassing and that's what
happened to casey here again i like
casey i think he's as far as journalists
go
i would say very good obviously he
wouldn't get a sub stack deal for
hundreds of thousands of dollars he
probably was making 100 150 000 working
for vox or recode and then he probably
had a salary doubled or triple by going
to subset that is the case
of the virtuoso elite journalist so the
people who are the top 25 journalists in
tech are we gonna make a hundred to two
hundred thousand and if they went to sub
stack they're going to double which is
quite ironic we'll get into that in a
minute and then he followed it up with
superhuman is the most juicy role-like
product to come out of this town since
juicer itself which is
super inaccurate and horrible what casey
doesn't know and i think this is a very
important thing for founders to
understand is
journalists have about five percent of
the information a great journalist like
casey or tara swisher they might get 20
of the information of what's going on in
a company if you had 20 of the
information about what was going on at a
company or in a newsroom would you have
the clear picture of what was going on
probably not and so this shows how
ill-informed journalists can be at their
worst now sometimes they get the whole
story they nail it and they get a
pulitzer that's certainly not this and
that would be the case with john kerry
right who did the incredible
there are no story so let's pause for a
second there and realize journalists are
at an information disadvantage and in
today's day and age
they want to dunk why do they want a
dunk casey wants to dunk on twitter
because he needs paid subscribers now he
is in fact an entrepreneur
and the more he dunks and the more
salacious to take or the more hot to
take the more he will be reported with
paid subscribers
so the idea that journalists are
suffering with 50 000 salaries and doing
it because they want to you know be
advocates for the truth that is not this
just be clear about that if you're
talking about a company like vice or vox
or sub stack authors
they are
venture backed businesses
or
they are entrepreneurial journalists
they will only make money
if they get subscribers and so link
dating headlines at vox or buzzfeed
generate the traffic they get which
turns into page views at its worst you
get things like gawker's worst worst
moments
and in terms of getting paid subscribers
you might have something like strategy
where that journalist or really an
analyst he ben thompson is like a
different beast he's 10 times more
knowledgeable than a casey newton who is
10 times more knowledgeable than a
buzzfeed rank and file entry level
reporter and that's because of networks
raw intelligence business experience any
number of factors or even the approach
so ben thompson's approaches listen i
want to impress the hell out of bill
gurley or bill simmons or kara swisher
or some other business leader really the
business leaders is who he's writing to
here casey newton is really angling for
like the woke mob and maybe dunking on
people it's a different thing
before we get into the ad let me just
tell you straight up your first job
posting free i'm not kidding
linkedin.com twist your first job
listing free nothing to lose okay now on
to the end too many small business
owners are busier than ever they spend
time searching for and interviewing the
wrong candidates for a job opening and
it would be much better for them to
spend their time growing their business
that's why linkedin jobs has made it
easier to get the candidates worth
interviewing faster and that's why
they're giving you the first job listing
for free at linkedin.com twist they know
it's gonna work here's how it works you
create a free post in minutes on
linkedin jobs and you reach the world's
largest professional network with over
750 million people i remember reading
this ad when it was like 150 million my
god they're growing it's like one of the
biggest growth stories inside of
microsoft in fact so they focus on
candidates with the skills and
experience that you need and you can use
screening questions to get your role in
front of the most qualified people we
love linkedin jobs at launch and in 2021
we've hired a third producer a
curriculum designer for founder
university and two more researchers and
we're still hiring for three more
positions using
you guessed it linkedin jobs so linkedin
jobs will help you find the candidates
that are worth interviewing faster every
week nearly 40 million job seekers visit
linkedin so post your job for free at
linkedin.com twist terms and conditions
apply because they're giving you
something for free